the 70-mile stretch of the River Mersey
may be the most plastic polluted water
in the world it's not the floating
rubbish in Deborah you can see it's the
tiny plastic particles you can't you
research by Greenpeace found the Mersey
proportionally far worse than the Great
Pacific Garbage Patch Mike duddy and his
team clean the Mercy's network of
waterways and say plastic gets into UK
rivers from almost everything we do the
cars are clothing wet whites is a huge
issue it's coming through the wastewater
system it's coming just from our general
activities of daily living we are the
plastic generation and make sure what
it's making which we really worried
about our children and our grandchildren
and the legacy that we're leaving them
we already know plastic waste has a
devastating impact on our planet but
micro plastic particles are so small
they often can't be picked up by water
filtration once they pollute their
country's rivers they contaminate its
marine life and are almost impossible to
remove micro plastics in water like the
Mersey estuary can be devastating for
marine life but it's also emerged humans
could be consuming up to a credit cards
worth of micro plastics every week
that's from drinking from plastic
bottles eating shellfish and salt and a
full impact of that on human health
isn't yet clear but awareness does
appear to be growing commuters on the
Mersey ferry to Liverpool suggest
attitudes are changing but there's still
a way to go do you find it confusing as
to what plastics you can recycle I
didn't know there was different plastics
but so yes that's precisely single-use
plastic kind of bothers me you try and
avoid it
yeah well extras classic bottle yeah
knots no straws just you know out of a
cup obviously not use it but if you if
you can't use it what do you use and
that's perhaps the issue without an
alternative
and legislation plastic will continue to
contaminate our rivers oceans and
animals
Sally Lockwood Sky News Liverpool